two we are back back back back
they said we would never show our faces
again because of the disgrace we
face on a every time we make an episode
but we come
back and defy the odds every time
today you know what you're talking about
i'm you know exactly what i'm talking
about
don't even pretend today we are joined
by activists
spiritual uh gurus leaders in their
community
and party activists of course i'm
talking about
chad and jt the party brothers
also known as chad goes deep oh that one
like threw my nose all the way
was that a sneeze or a cough it was kind
of it was a sneeze but like it was all
through my nose
bro i felt that one good thing i don't
my nose isn't really stuffy because i
felt like two
hot jets of air through my nostrils that
could have been a mess
anyway party burrows awesome
excellent dudes i'm actually really
excited to have these two guys on
uh you guys may remember them from
they go to city councils and lobby for
the rights of bros
for example they wanted to bring unity
to
huntington beach by erecting a paul
walker statue
they pitched that to the city council
they also pitched uh
they went to the la city council to
lobby against
you know clamping down on parties in the
hollywood hills because they say that
parties change their life they're great
um i don't know how
deep i need to go in their discography
but recently they were in
actually super viral moment they had at
huntington beach which they were on like
ellen and howard stern they were just
handing out free masks and people were
like coughing on their face and telling
them to
kill themselves and all this horrible
[ __ ] so really interesting
uh today's episode is sponsored by honey
as well
and please remember that if you click
that join
button on youtube you get this episode a
day early
and not a dollar short or a day late
it's a day
and a dollar short it's a day early and
a dollar
in your pocket you pay us though we
don't pay you so
that's the saying isn't really
applicable to the situation at all
so today's episode is brought to you by
honey and with that being said
please enjoy our our uh really fruitful
and productive conversation
with the party bros with us
today is uh well the channel is called
chad goes deep but there's actually we
have two protagonists
with us jt and chad
uh the also dubbed the party bros social
activists
and uh party enthusiasts do you believe
i've described
you guys correctly
i think that's perfect yeah i like
partying
yeah we started as party enthusiasts now
we're
activists but we're both at the same
time for sure
yeah i think both those things can
certainly live together i don't see why
not
well why does um why does chad get all
the credit
and the channel name what's where's
where's the love for jt
well chad chad started it without me and
actually i was like a little bit
reluctant to jump in because i'm a
little bit lazy
and then um after i helped him write
this speech for
for uh getting a statue for paul walker
which was our first cause and probably
the one dearest to our hearts
and then after that kind of got a lot of
attention
i was like okay yeah i'm all the way in
now but the wheels were already kind of
in motion so
as i i think chad is this straw that
stirs the drink so
and he works way way harder than me so
i'm i'm just grateful to be on the ride
with him but sometimes i do get a little
bit jealous
but i'm just super grateful to my dog
well you're too kind yeah it was kind of
i mean jt's got
a genius noggin so you know he's really
the brains behind those
a lot of those speeches and uh so
yeah it was kind of like once once we we
kind of once we kind of hit big it was
the two of us but like the original
channel was chad goes deep but
um i think i think i think we've sort of
been able to solidify the chat and jt
name as a pair
and sometimes we try like chad has tried
really hard like when the hulu
we gotta and it sounds like i'm bragging
out but we have a development deal at
hulu
and like i was on the text chain and
chad was like yeah say chad and jt
in the headline and i was like oh my
dog's got my back and then chad goes
deep and i was like well chad tried his
best
there you go yeah you guys seem like
like like total bros and
i have to say i find it quite charming
how sweet
and uh caring you guys seem to be not
just about each other but just kind of
about the world in general
when you think about bros uh you don't
necessarily
always you know that's not always
synonymous with
sweet and caring how did you go how do
you find a couple bros that are just so
sweet and charming and nice
um well yeah i think that's what we've
always
how we've always been and with our
activism we've tried to sort of
present this new kind of bro cuz like
you know bros have gotten a bad name in
the past 20 years and rightfully so i
mean there's a lot of
uh bros out there who have ventured into
the realm of being unchill
um but uh you know our squad you know
it's
we've always been very sweet and just
happy and fun and we love
good times and being inclusive so i
think with our activism we really wanted
to portray that to the world like
there can be nice bros out there who
you know love everyone and they don't
they don't have fun at
other people's expense and stuff like
that and
stuff like that you guys might you might
be called a new breed of bros one might
be able to say about you guys
a new breed of bro that sounds chill i'm
into that yeah
yeah yeah i think progressive i got
lucky too i grew up with a lot of really
nice
hot dudes who were like could have been
douches but they were actually
pretty chill and and even beyond that
they
were like like virtuous guys i was
probably the biggest douche out of the
crew because i was upset
and then i just kind of learned that i
was attracted to being around nice
people because they made me feel better
so then i was like all right well i'll
try and
do that in the stuff i put out there oh
that's right
that's a really wholesome uh insight
yeah yeah are you
are you guys parents chill that's an
interesting question
i mean our dads are for sure alphas
um my mom's super chill though
my mom and i are pretty much one in the
same really she's like
i love my mom so much and i love my
parents so much but yeah our dad's
definitely come from like the
or my dad you know it comes from like
the very stoic
you know get [ __ ] done is he on
chill bro is that what you mean by alpha
no
my dad no no he's very he's very sweet
actually but he's very sort of like
i do pull-ups i go to work i eat steak
and i'm kind of that way too but with a
little more stoke i guess
i know exactly what you mean to the mig
yeah yeah
uh but he's the sweetest too so he's
definitely i'd consider him a chill bro
for sure oh that's enough
jt what about your dad the reason i
asked that of course is because
i just wonder where you get this really
nice world outlook i wonder if your
if your parents are chill bros my
parents are
super loving very charismatic my dad was
a really like um
hard driving business guy very like uh
kind of
entrepreneurial and then my mom is like
the life of the party
i would say both of them are pretty
intense and pretty alpha but that they
both are really
uh caring people too so i think i just
kind of
i think i could see my dad sometimes
like aching to be a chill bro but
he just had to work so hard to get to
where he was that chillness got lost
along the way like he couldn't afford to
be chill that's interesting and then
i was in a luckier position where i was
like oh but life's a little bit easier
for me so i can probably be chill
and then i don't know if that's
necessarily correlates like you can't be
chill and
get past hardship sure that's how i
perceived him
chill is a little bit of a privilege
none for her sometimes i think
privilege do you think yeah for sure oh
for sure yeah
yeah and um is that the first time
you've been asked that question
no no
um yeah i'm stuck to talk about it
um so what you guys i've noticed you
guys saying alpha
a few times are you guys alpha what does
it mean to be alpha because you almost
are using it
well i'm not quite sure how are you
using it almost like uh do you want to
be alpha or not alpha and the bro code
it's a good question these are great
questions yeah i think i think i grapple
with it i think i've
had like an aversion to being alpha like
i kind of associate it with
dominance and overcompensating and and
and like unfairness but but there's
moments where i definitely
want to be alpha so i think i'm always
struggling with finding a balance
between
getting stuff done but then also still
being you know happy for others and kind
of perceiving the world as a
separate place yeah and i think yeah i
mean chad and i talk about that
once once in a while it's definitely
something that comes up we're like how
can we be like
people who get stuff done and i think
actually a lot of comedians
act like they're not alpha like their
public personas are very like
self-deprecating like oh i'm like a dope
but then like if you actually saw them
behind the scenes you'd be like
no you're kind of like uh a gnarly
badass
but they don't want to like present that
i guess so is that what you're telling
me that you
do are you doing that right now
i don't think so i don't think so
yeah i grappled with it too uh when i
was younger
because i was always very passive and uh
i was like
you know in high school people were like
you need to stand up for yourself a
little bit more and i was like
but i was always just so like
happy-go-lucky i was like what does that
mean
uh so but i've sort of made peace with
it where i'm like you know i
i don't think i'd venture into the realm
of beta
per se but it's like i'm i'm passive and
like i like being
you know nice to everyone and just
having fun um
and i think i've been able to make my
way through life that way and it's it's
worked to my benefit and so i yeah
um but yeah go ahead i always thought it
was cool when like if someone would like
take a jab
at chad he would just kind of laugh and
roll with it and it kind of defused the
jab
in a way where i was like oh he's almost
above like the alpha
beta he's the omega thinking
without being oppositional to it which i
thought was like kind of
the maybe most effective way to go about
that right that
is chad can i may i notice a coincidence
about you that maybe you can address
you should trad kroger is the exact name
of the singer of nickelback what a
strange coincidence
uh when uh what do you think about that
coincidence or
it's very odd uh if i can be real it
fires me up
every day i mean i'm a huge nickelback
fan
uh photograph rockstar i mean how you
remind me that you know i love jam into
those songs so
i'm just honored to to share the name
with with such a uh
a talented singer was there ever a point
in your childhood when
nickelback became famous and then you're
like oh there's another chad kroger out
there
uh did your life change at all when that
happened
i think it made me more confident you
know i was like oh i share the same name
as this
like because i was listening to how you
remind me one time i was going to like
taco bell with
my buddy devin and how you remind me was
on and i was like this song was
yeah it was like all the time
i remember him telling me about that yet
yeah yeah impactful story huh
yeah yeah i was like dude this song is
all
time and he's like well you know you
share the same name and i'm like
all right i think i'm gonna make
something of myself in life
damn and you've held true to that thank
you thank you
i hope i do you i wonder if maybe you'll
become the greater chad kroger
is that your hope um
maybe you'll maybe when people hear chad
kroger they'll no longer heal
think of nickelback they'll think of
chad goes deep and jt
the the alpha or i mean really the alpha
brain but the omega
omega omega bro
you guys get what i'm saying right dude
i did it so well yeah
um i don't know i think i think in an
ideal world
you know we'd have like uh just chad
kroger
sort of uh dominating all all
areas of the culture you know like music
that's chad kroger nickelback maybe
activism
but me and jt together so chad kroger
and jt
so um but i don't know if i'd ever want
to surpass him
in legend status i think i always want
to stay on par with him so let me ask
you this if you find that your legend is
growing
alarmingly fast or you're going to dial
it back
to not uh to not surpass
the master the sensei chad kroger
original
i think i just hit him up and i'd be
like dude you better start working on a
new album
yeah let's let's let's rise together my
dad yeah
right yeah and it's like that poem from
aquila and the b and coach carter
i think it's by marianne williamson
about how you don't help the world by
dimming your own like
you know when you shine you give other
people the permission to shine so i
think the more chad grows more he'll
inspire nickelback to just
keep putting out thoughtful rock and
roll all
they say there's i think a confucius
said all chad krogers rise together
yeah i love confucius horizon chad rises
with all boats
yeah exactly exactly
yeah yeah i feel like we're on the same
wavelength you guys i really
feel like we're connecting already in
the short term completely yeah
so when did you first of all i'm
wondering how did you guys meet you guys
are so well connected
i feel like you guys are even in the
same room just like on laptops in
different parts of the living room
[Laughter]
we actually met at this rager um our
buddy ben
benji was throwing a rager um and it was
kind of a flop to be honest you know
like
um benji's dad would wouldn't bail and
it was just like kind of you know
like i remember at one point kellen said
he was gonna go make a quesadilla which
is like
gonna kill the party so in a moment of
desperation i
got the mount chugmore four hose beer
bong from my truck
and i was gonna chug it with kellen
reese and landon
and then um but landon couldn't because
he was on antibiotics so
uh jt stepped in and
once he twisted the nozzle it was like a
cosmic connection
so you guys connected over a beer bong
yeah and i just knew right away like he
had the vibes i was kind of looking for
in my life like was the kind of person i
wanted to be around i was like okay
we're going to be bros for a minute
and then uh we kind of lost track of
each other and then we both kind of
circled back in our 20s and we're like
hey like i saw what he was working on
with the activism stuff and he he
thought i could help out with that and
then we just kind of uh
i don't know started clicking and and
we've been kind of inseparable ever
since yeah what about that beer bong
just
i feel like was it he hit it super fast
and hard and he released the
the lever i mean what what what were the
the
the fizzle the carbonated pops and that
uh oh well he was incredible because i'm
not very good at beer bonds but he could
open up his gullet in a really smooth
way where the
yeah you can see from the way the
alcohol is coming down in the tube
how someone's dealing with it you can
tell if someone's pressing back against
it if they're resisting it
and he just had a smooth pathway and the
beard just flowed down effortlessly
and i was like that's really good
technique but even beyond that it was
like dude he got the beer bong to get
the party going
right and i just i respected that
initiative like a lot of people were
just sitting back and they were going to
let this party die
i'm not going gently bro i'm getting the
beer bong and we're going to [ __ ] get
this thing going excuse my language
and i was like all right that's the kind
of person that's the kind of person i
want to be around do not
chad gently into that uh dark night what
is this saying
yeah we will not go gently into the
night we will survive today we
no you're not doing independence day
you're doing church yeah but do not chad
quietly into this oh no it's not
churchill it's a problem
yeah it's uh it's like larkin oh
cs eliot tsm bill pullman said
independence day we will not go
quietly into the night is that it yeah
yeah that's what i could i think
he ripped off that poem but basically do
not
chad quietly is is what i was getting at
it's funny because i feel like
dylan thomas sorry can you read the
quote for us but
chad instead of like go say chad
yeah of course um
i'll go quickly as well i'll go quickly
to the poem but not
into the good night uh yeah please chad
do not go chadli into that good night
old age should burn and rave at close of
day
rage rage against the dying of the chad
wow beautiful beautiful
[Applause]
um yeah and uh that was beautiful jt but
yeah and also when
when jt hit the beer bong like the thing
i love about jt is his emotional iq
is like surpasses anyone i know
and he's just like he loses passion and
his vocabulary like
it's just his dome is just like his
intellect is like
it's it impresses me every time so like
i'm always
he always one-ups it so the way he hit
the beer bong i could see like the
passion and also the the
empathy and the way he he chugged it if
that makes sense like he was like
he's like i'm with you and we will not
let this party
bust you know it's interesting how much
you can tell about someone from a beer
bong
yeah yeah for real right i've always
thought that i feel like for ethan the
party would have started with the
quesadillas
yeah i don't know i'm not a party bro
the quesadilla is just the start yeah
well if he would have been making
quesadillas for the whole party maybe
but it was a solo
uh venture so we were like dude you're
kind of just taken away from the energy
we need from you
like it's kind of you put too much
pressure on your boys but when there's a
party and one of your boys kind of like
just goes off and starts doing his own
like internal thing you're like hey we
kind of need you here to like keep the
party strong
yeah yeah how did you guys get involved
in social justice because i feel like
that was a beautiful new chapter in your
guys's life
and i feel like your social justice
really has resonated
with people tell me about how that got
started
uh well we were first introduced to
like civic duty and city councils
because this this poke shop
uh slam and salmon was gonna get closed
i think for like zoning laws or
something
and so you know we went with a bunch of
dudes
to talk to the council about how good
the pokey is you know like
like max there if you know him like he
he'll put on togarashi ponzu
avocado bamboo rice and
overload it with salmon right and so we
were like we need to keep this dude
around and um
that was our first introduction and then
and like
you know around the last election time
we just saw that the country was kind of
really divided and uh
we're like what can we do like what what
brings people together
and jt and i just sort of looked at each
other and we're like paul walker
oh paul walker i thought you're gonna
say pokey oh that too
i mean for sure uh but then like yeah
sure yeah oh yeah dude paul walker and
pokey i mean you can't beat that comment
yeah yeah and then i hooked up with jt
and we we uh
wrote the speech together um actually do
you guys mind if i watch the video is
that okay
yeah it goes yeah i don't want to
catalog your guys's illustrious work in
activism uh
can i set it up so they can watch along
or should i just play it
uh last time it was so laggy the website
well you guys are familiar with it so
maybe you can just listen is that
yeah is it okay would you guys if you
just hear it yeah whatever way you guys
want to do it i'm just gonna i'm gonna
go ahead and play some
an excerpt here so this is the san
clemente city council is that where you
guys are from san clemente
mm-hmm yeah i'm from next door in san
juan capistrano but essentially
i mean they're well i shouldn't say
they're interchangeable but they're
right next door to each other
okay so here we go you are potent
and by the way how do you get into the
city council chamber do you just show up
like how does it it's open to anyone any
citizen can go in there and say that i
want to comment on either stuff that's
on the agenda or public comment which
means basically anything
and they will give you your three
minutes that's amazing and how do you
get the footage you know what i mean is
that available to the public too
yeah huh yeah it's public domain so they
have it on their website
and you can just download the whole
council video
yeah how long did it take before the
video went up after the speech
dude actually we didn't even put it up
like a journalist was there for the san
clemente times i think and
he threw it up on their facebook page
and then it went viral from there
no way yeah so no one even really knew
it was us they're like who are these who
are these dudes uh
and then so yeah but uh then we put it
up after we were like this is us and
people were like okay
so you guys were you guys were not
looking for media attention you were
there simply just
to spread the word of paul walker to
bring peace and unity to san clemente
and the globe at large really huh yeah
yeah
okay let's watch let's let's let's see
what this is all about
incredible that they haven't upgraded
their uh video technology
since at least they have video
technology
council my name is chad kroger first i
just want to say i'm truly honored to be
here
uh to be in a city where you can have a
surf session and then go to a city
council meeting within the span of an
hour
i think that just shows that the
american dream is still very much alive
so thank you
all right to the serious stuff i i stand
before you here today in the midst of
gnarly times
i'm a freelance journalist and after
interviewing hundreds of people
i've witnessed first hand the
ever-growing divide between americans
and families torn apart over political
differences
it's in times like these we need a
unifying figure we can all turn to
a beacon of headlights that can guide us
down the dusty road
i was 11 years old when my first love
ashley betrayed me by moving to newport
beach
i felt lost alone bombed
and it was in that melancholy that my
dad took me to see the fast and
furious where for an hour and 47 minutes
i transcended my worries
because i just met my new hero paul
walker afterwards at carl's jr i thought
about what paul taught me
i think the most inspiring thing was the
fact that even after
dominic treto beat him in that first
race paul still managed to bet his
sister
pretty inspiring and another thing is
the fact that he still saved vince even
though vince was flexing on him the
entire movie and questioned his love for
tuna sandwiches
um which i think is a true testament to
his character
i wonder if they like vin diesel and i
just want to go off book here you know
it wasn't just fast and the furious he
inspired me in a ton of other movies as
well
uh skulls meet the details they must
have been like what in the [ __ ]
am i so ultimately i'm gonna skip to the
end
so i want to see the proposal oh you
have another bro here who's this bro
that was a bodhi of the paul walker
initiative
yeah just real quick best known for his
installation of white cube 2003
uh the new fast and furious is fast
approaching it comes out next month
and so we don't have much time um
so i'm just going to ask you guys
straight up how can we get started
when can we break ground
do you have any comments
all right i'll let you guys think about
that thank you so much
so you are petitioning the city to build
a statue to paul walker your hero
yeah yeah how was the reception how do
you find that the city council receives
your
your your ideas uh
for that one i don't know i don't know
if they
took it as seriously at first but the
reception
nationwide uh was pretty awesome i mean
you saw how many people loved
paul walker and and like it it was like
it just sort of um yeah reassured me
that like
you know a lot of people were like yes
we do need this statue so i was like all
right cool
like people are on board so i think that
spoke to the council and they become
more friendly would you be in favor of
say like replacing the washington
monument with this
giant statue of ball walker
george washington yeah george washington
the washington monument in dc
i just mean what i mean to say is that
maybe you're thinking too small like
san clemente is just a kind of a small
beach town but i'm thinking maybe we go
bigger washington dc you know
national monument thoughts yeah
yeah i mean yeah i'd like to
be do they have a good break there i'd
like i'd like paul's statue to be
surrounded by pretty solid waves
washington dc i don't know if they have
a solid potomac doesn't go off
that's a really good point maybe he
wouldn't be honored there
but i was thinking we could just replace
the lincoln monument with the
with paul walker yeah
lincoln's pretty dope though yeah i
think let's leave
a good monument um
we talk a lot about vin diesel on this
show do you guys have any
yeah it's about his character yeah
i love him yeah his performance in the
first fascinating furious i think is one
of the most
commanding performances of my lifetime
i mean he really does he just he's just
like this he has this gravity to him or
you're like yeah that's the leader
definitely has gravity outlaw crew that
drives you know 10 second cars
thank you today to honey for sponsoring
this episode
we all shop online and listen we've all
seen that promo code field at checkout
and it taunts us
it humiliates us it dares us to i says
to you i dare you to go spend an hour
scouring the internet
for a code because you know you could
save five ten twenty
maybe even in this case a hundred
and eleven dollars and fifty cents this
is totally real
yeah tell me about your experience
saving with honey um i was just shopping
on levi's
the website and some stuff were already
on sale
so i would have never gone to look for a
coupon on top of it
i just assumed it was already like
pretty good price
um and i have honey still installed so
when i was just doing checkout as
regular it showed me that it's a hundred
dollars off of 200.
that's crazy that's literally like 50
off yeah
here's how honey works uh it's a free
browser extension
that automatically searches the internet
for promo codes
and automatically applies the best one
it finds to your cart
when you're checking out honey supports
over 30 000 stores
online ranging from tech gaming products
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click
apply coupon pardon me
honey's like no coughing no i'm kidding
they're chilled
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it
find for that site if honey finds a
working coupon you'll watch as the price
drops boom as ila has proven
it works and honestly for me honey is
like a game changer it's ridiculous it's
just so
fun you're like oh [ __ ] i literally
would have spent this money yeah for
this magical
plugin um
honey has found it's over 17 million
members
over two billion in savings
wow that's nuts if you don't already
have honey you could be straight up
missing out on free savings it's
literally free
installs in a few seconds and by getting
it you'll be doing
yourself a solid you'll be doing us a
solid
you'll be supporting this podcast it's a
win win win win win
get hunting for free at jointhoney.com
h3 that's join honey dot com
slash h3
this is one of the comments that one of
the city council members had to say
about you guys may i read it to you
yes please he said i guess every
generation needs their cheech
and chong and spokoli characters but
chad and jt
fell way short in their efforts i enjoy
a good sense of humor
and wish they had used better material
that would have made them
funny instead of predictable how do you
guys respond to the ch
to uh chris hamilton council member
dude that's good it's good constructive
criticism we'll come back stronger the
next time
yeah it actually kind of cracks me up
like we did laguna beach one time
and the council member afterwards like
this was solid but it's not your best
work
oh my god yeah i wonder if the count the
uh all the council members in the area
are just waiting for the day that the
party bros into their chamber
that happened in newport yeah yeah tell
me about it what did they say when you
walked in
jt do you want it like we just i was i
was just back in chat up
uh but like it was funny too like at the
newport beach one like the mayor was
wearing
rainbow sandals i think at the meeting
which was like okay this is a chill
meeting
and then when chad came up the the mayor
was like
chad kroger
yeah that's awesome yeah you guys are
getting two maybe your activism
efforts are becoming too renowned you
guys might have to go up north or some
somewhere to another coastline where
people don't know you as much
yeah we went to delaware last year
and um it was interesting seeing the
contrast in city council meetings like
they were a lot more
you know i don't think they were wearing
rainbow sandals no at that meeting and
they they were not
down with our cause uh because we're
just you know
we we had a we came there for good
reason because the university of
delaware their ragers were getting
a little more restricted so we came to
to appeal that
uh but yeah so we're starting to venture
to to
more different states and to say what up
that's good
i think it's important to spread your
activism i mean california's benefited
so many so much from you guys soquels
particularly
that i think there's a lot of youth and
not just youth but really just general
population that could benefit
from your guys's kind of missionary work
even at this point i would call it
do you guys ever consider going to other
countries to spread stoke
and uh activism for sure
yeah yeah we'd love to do chad goes deep
in like russia or china russia yeah
yeah china seems really appealing right
now yeah
yeah i think there's a lot to
investigate so i'd love to love to go in
there with an open mind and just
bring our dank vibes to what's going on
damn i would actually
love to watch you guys go deep in china
yeah well dude after our last video they
were like reaching out
to the chinese government well not the
government i don't think
uh but like some news networks uh they
want us to come on
oh for real yeah yeah after the mass
video oh they oh they're trying to do
anti-us propaganda over there
yeah we didn't deduce that immediately
but after other people explained to us
how media works over there we kind of
got hip to what their angle might be
dude chinese government one did he use
you guys is probably
gonna do that no you're like no thank
you we're doing our own propaganda here
in the united states
not really propaganda it's just kind of
the truth but i wouldn't necessarily
trust that in the hands of the
chinese government yeah and we're pretty
open-minded too i mean we'll go on
a lot of different platforms and so we
were like oh maybe we could like get our
message in
even well they'll just translate it and
be like
they'll be like you know we'd have to be
live
it would have to be live so we know that
they wouldn't edit
right yeah yeah but they would just put
subtitles possibly that just
totally [ __ ] you guys over oh that'd
be pretty hilarious yeah we did we'd
have to put in one of our boys to
translate
bring in a chinese speaking bro oh yeah
our boy schneider used to teach english
yesterday yes yeah bring it bring it a
mandarin speaking bro to translate live
that would be yeah dude that's a good i
love that yeah
schneider would kill that oh did he come
in like what up
and he starts translating did i know you
could he could do it well for us too
he'd get the vernacular in there now
i'm excited wow i'd love to send you
guys to just like
ethiopia or brazil or somewhere i just
want to see you guys
spread i think you know a lot of these
countries are developing and i think
like introducing you guys might speed up
the development process you know what i
mean
oh thank you yeah yeah be a catalyst for
acceleration
yeah 100 billion
yeah so um
going back a little bit the first time i
saw you guys you were advocating for
partying in the hollywood hills i'm
gonna do you guys mind if i pull this up
and watch it for a bit
no please do huh yeah okay here we go
next speaker
yes sir identify yourself what up
council my name is chad kroger
um i'm an activist and house party
enthusiast
over the past week i've been in a state
of deep despair
upon hearing the news that la is trying
to outlaw house parties in the hollywood
hills
i am here determined to stop this future
atrocity house parties were the bedrock
of my development as a young man in san
clemente
my first introduction to manhood came
when the captain of my water polo team
boomer kingsley asked me to shotgun a
tall can of bud light in front of the
whole squad at his end of the season
bash
his parents were in tahoe at the time so
we tore that weekend up
it was epic and i was super stoked
my newfound confidence gave me the
courage to ask out the most popular girl
in school
lauren stockholder to prom that year she
rejected me and i had to go with stacy
mcmillan
but i didn't care because i was so amped
on chugging with my boys
that's what house parties do raging at
house parties is the truth
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa speaker please
come this struck me as rude how we cut
you off were you out of time or
yeah i was out of time and that actually
that's her
herb lesson he's like one of our best
friends now
oh for real really yeah yeah yeah he's a
legend
i was gonna ask how you guys kind of are
received in these
in these city councils where they don't
really know what's coming at them
i think at first they're a little thrown
off because like
we're so passionate and we're coming
from the heart
you know and it's like i think i think
we're i think a lot of them
inside they're like leaping with joy
because they're like finally they're
talking about stuff i want to talk about
you know things that matter
like like partying you know and not and
not like
you know street lights or whatever
homeless people and [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah you get different
perspectives on that
yeah yeah and you know it's fine too
it's like la like the people
or just different places like sometimes
the people who speak before and after us
are even kind of more absurd than us
sometimes
sometimes we're a welcome relief because
we're being pretty chill about
everything
that's true you guys are not hostile of
all things actually i didn't want to cut
i definitely wanted to enjoy uh jt has a
as obviously an impassioned speech as
well so
let's watch it oh thank you yeah
identify yourself
what up council my name is jt parr i'm
also here to defend
parties in the hollywood hills i grew up
like most kids
worried i couldn't bench two plates that
i wouldn't fit in
that i wouldn't find love then i
discovered partying and suddenly all
those worries went to the wayside
i didn't need love i had keg stands
i discovered i was great at raging and
it revealed wonderful things about
myself
i could relate to bros regardless of
what kind of bro they were
i could be at a party and moon people
and everyone would laugh you know be
witty
or i could play beer pong and compete
with real integrity
in short i fulfilled my potential if you
outlaw house parties
you may keep the volume down but an
externality is that you may keep people
from bonding
america needs bonding people need to put
aside their differences
and find common joy there's no more
effective environment for that than a
freaking rager
this is best exemplified in me and
chad's relationship we were star-crossed
he is surfer
me a bodybuilder thank you thank you and
i want to
jt would you consider that like your um
i have a dream oh man
yeah because that is my dream is for
everybody to rage and not be judged by
you know uh super official differences
but by the content of their party
yeah do you what was the law you guys
were lobbying against by the way what
was it they were trying to
you guys were you know fighting against
what was it they were trying to do
yeah well i was i was literally i was at
the gym and i was like doing sprints
so i was fired up already and i saw in
the news like
on the local news is like la city
council
making move to ban house parties in the
hollywood hills
um so i didn't really investigate much
further beyond that i just saw what i
needed to see and i hit up jt and he was
like well let's go to the council right
now so
next morning when they met we just
cruised over and yeah
and did they follow through with the law
or did you guys enact change
no they followed through yeah i think
they were shutting down people who were
renting airbnbs and having like 300
people parties
yeah because it was like destroying the
neighborhood and then i was like well
sounds like the neighborhood needs to
get a little bit more dank
yeah yeah i think if destroying if that
if that's what destroying the
neighborhood is then tear
my neighborhood up you know what i mean
for sure for sure
yeah i love it um
you guys had a actually you guys had a
really viral moment recently
down at huntington beach you guys were
attempting to be what i can really
consider being good bros
handing off free masks because there's a
lot of people out there without masks
and i think
you know it's easy to assume well maybe
they just didn't have one right i think
that's what you guys were assuming
when you saw people without masks yeah
yeah like i i serve huntington a lot and
we get
pokey at bear flag a lot which shout out
they have the best pokey
and uh yeah we just thought a lot of
people weren't wearing masks so we just
assumed
you know naturally that the supply chain
was boned up sure
yeah of course so you guys went out
there
to hand out free masks but
the reactions were actually quite
hostile did that surprise you
or many of them were
um i don't think it was totally
surprising i think uh
people don't like being told what to do
and we we kind of understood that
uh before we went out there you know
um i i often related to like my little
league experiences where i didn't want
to wear a cup
i thought they were just cumbersome and
then oh that's a great analogy
yeah it wasn't until the third baseman
on my team simon got drilled
uh where you were a cup that i realized
the importance of taking like safety
precautions oh that's
that's such a good analogy yeah so i
think sometimes for people
they they will react hostilely but but
once they are affected by something
they tend to tone it down well some of
the people were really awesome i mean
one dude like coughed in your guys's
faces did that surprise you
definitely surprised yeah and i mean i
was checking out
yeah you guys spent a lot of time around
unmasked
uh people are you have you been tested
for covet i've been worried about covid
um i was worried for sure i mean it was
it was
what like three or four weeks ago now so
uh i was worried for sure after it and i
just sort of holed up
in my apartment after um
but i haven't been tested i haven't
experienced any symptoms but i've been
super safe and just wearing a mask and
pretty much stand by myself
that's good yeah i've been tested three
times actually and i've been fortunate
to come back negative with all of them i
was really really
scared at first like too scared i have
kind of like hypochondriac
tendencies where i always think i'm sick
so this was kind of a bad
uh you know setting for me but i've
actually kind of
adjusted to just this new normal and the
way i've kind of
feel better about it is i just try to
work out a lot and take vitamins and and
just be as healthy as possible so if i
do get it
hopefully i'll be all right that's a
good approach you must have really been
freaked out when that dude coughed on
you
yeah no that's yeah yeah actually like
i i was a little more scared than jt i
think at that moment because
jt was like reassuring that he was like
we were six feet we were six feet
but you know that's a crime actually
should we show that yeah i will show it
but
yeah that's why we blurred the dude's
face because after the reaction of the
huntington one we were like oh we don't
want it was chad actually called me and
was like hey we have to like
huh we have to look out for this person
like i don't know people are reacting to
the video very emotionally he's like
he's like
we should blur his face you know what
you guys are the sweetest bros i mean
the guy didn't deserve that but yet you
guys
i think the bro code really even extends
to unrolly people i'm learning about you
guys
oh thank you thank you yeah
yeah yeah i was a yeah i was
yeah that nevermind
well i was really surprised actually
with the video
um even though i know a lot of people
are
refusing to wear the mask it was just
shocking to see it in that way
and this video was going so viral it was
being sent to me by
random people too oh really yeah people
in israel
mm-hmm
[Laughter]
um yeah we we didn't expect the response
i mean it was
it was pretty wild and it blew up you
know within like a day we're like whoa
like this is taking off probably maybe
bigger than anything else
we've done well where did it take off
the most because i've noticed
like your youtube channel is kind of
small but it seems like you guys
get out way more is it are you guys big
on facebook or
instagram where are people watching your
content the most
uh instagram um really
what's your yeah where do you guys
prefer people watch you guys
instagram instagram and youtube yeah um
like yeah it's chat goes deep instagram
then jtpar14
and then just chat goes deep youtube um
that's sort of
the main ones but yeah it is interesting
like i think a lot of times our videos
are shared without
um us being credited
you know like because it's like public
domain and people will be like oh this
is just like a city council like this
isn't
right i don't know who we are so they
just like the the paul walker on this
house parties one they just very true
you know the first time i saw you guys
was one of your random city council
clips i think i saw the news or
something
and you know people are just like look
at these jokers
and you're right i think you guys are
even more famous than you get credit for
i think the bronis oh thank you
is uh spreading even even further than
you guys realize
let me let me pull up the the clip of
you guys trying to give out free mass
i think the reason why it went so viral
is that you guys were so sweet and nice
about
it and then people were just it seems
like such an objectively
nice thing they could just say no thank
you right yeah
yeah reactions were so crazy well here
let me just pull up a quick
excerpt this is from the uh huntington
beach solving the masks
shortage is the name of the video when
chad goes deep
so no i'm good thanks dammit are you pro
mask bro
you want a mask it's all fake dude come
on i love that [ __ ] man
i'm good man oh man that's just
something i like i like freedom dog i
like i like fresh air
just shut down the [ __ ] country
that's [ __ ] dude i'm good but does
we're in a mass shut down the country
when you close down half the economy
yeah i think so but can we open it up
quicker if we all wear masks no
dude that's a talking point on the tv
bro i wasn't quite sure
um i wasn't quite sure what he was
talking about you know his points didn't
make total sense to me he was saying
he was saying that wearing masks shuts
down the country did you understand what
he was saying
i didn't quite
i think he meant just the lockdown in
general like he thought was probably an
overreaction to the virus
and i do think part of the reason people
liked the video or
responded to it was because we
we got these this wide range of
responses that were all kind of
emblematic of
just like uh i don't know
not logical thinking that people were
using to be against mass like some
people use religion some people think
it's the media
some people just think like it's just
fake some people just think it's just
fake yeah and we kind of
we touched a couple of those different
things and and it didn't feel like
people were thinking about it deeply it
just felt like they were kind of just
like emotionally responding to it a
little bit that's true
how did like uh people anti-mask people
respond to your guys's video
online you mean yeah online in general
did you guys get any hate for these
videos
there's a lot of debate in the comment
section going on um
there's been a few nasty messages but
not
you know maybe in the single digits i
mean i
i think the fact that we're we were just
so sweet in the video i mean it's like
you can't
it's not like we were we were like
telling people to wear
like you need to wear a mask or like
antagonizing them we were just saying
like
hey if you want free masks you can have
them so absolutely
yeah i don't think there's a lot of room
to to
hate unless you're really really
passionate about
not wearing a mask
let me continue watching yeah they say
it's not a mask it's a muzzle
well i'm not planning on biting anybody
so i guess i don't understand that
analogy either but
for everyone
what does that mean
yeah i don't even know just a benevolent
superseding
hey what's intelligence rick so [ __ ]
cool
dude rick is the coolest dude do you
wear a mask
god does love me do you wear a mask
[ __ ] you what the hell what the hell did
you guys do
that was the crazy like those two
sentences just did not connect
me
[Laughter]
yeah but honest to god like when i when
i reflect back on that dude i know like
maybe his thinking isn't helpful for the
situation we're in but like
i don't know he's a pretty hilarious
dude right to cruise by
on a on a bike and just yeah he's ready
to
throw down just drop back up in arms
like he doesn't know maybe chatter i do
muay thai or something like that and
then he just was like i don't care dude
you're just not going to tell me how to
live just [ __ ] you bro yeah
yeah yeah yeah props in a way right i
think that spirit probably helps us with
some things but it's just probably not
the right attitude it's not the attitude
we need right now but maybe there are
times when we
yeah when he first started yelling at us
i got scared
for a little bit and then and i started
realizing oh this dude is squared up
24 7. he's ready to go so it was like
you know he was just talking and then
but he stayed under that bridge i think
for like
an hour just like you know squared up
just like that
yeah i was just scared i was in sandals
too i was like i can't i took him off
yeah
did you guys ever actually feel like
maybe under threat of violence at any
point during these videos
i mean kind of like you guys mentioned
you should probably be ready to run when
you're gonna offer a mask to someone
yeah
yeah i think i think briefly you know
but it i think we're we always sort of
have the the
method of de-escalating the situation
with
radical kindness and just you know and
so i
you know if someone really wants to
throw down like
yeah i i don't think it's ever gotten to
the point where i'm like okay this
person's actually going to
make good on their thread well let me
ask you this yeah are you guys
are you guys good fighters do you guys
think you could throw down in the event
of
violence i i can wrestle pretty good i
think that guy would have
beat my ass he's very big dude yeah yeah
the people in huntington who were
threatened who got in our face
i think the majority of them i was like
yes guy will probably kick
my ass but but but i feel like i can get
away
at the minimum yeah yeah
but is that why you guys practice
sprinting just so you know that you can
because you said you were sprinting in
the gym the other day just kind of
keeping nimble at all times
that's why i sprint you know because i'm
strictly uh
flight yeah just fly there's no fight
just flight
yeah yeah i'm ready to go you don't need
fight yeah
exactly yeah and i had more mass to give
away
yeah that's all that bad let me keep
watching this is too good
what i think oh he's coming back
do you need a mask get ready to run
okay what else you want just to give
you're not making my [ __ ] rights and
not my rights first of all
we're just trying to hand out i think
you don't you don't believe in a mask
i don't that's cool i can leave it alone
you want something with me come on and
get this no we're not trying to fight
anyone we just
yeah do you want him for the mask maybe
we do a happy hour at sharkies later
well we learned a valuable lesson and
then here i've got the
the clip here where um where the dude
coughs on you let me pull it up
here we go are they cool
no they're not that sweet but they're
all right dude can i just sit
oh dude oh you guys have eyewear on i
didn't notice that in this video that's
good you know yeah we watched goggles
for that one which voucher just endorsed
so we were kind of
yeah you guys may have prevented getting
yeah the virus from wearing those
goggles
who knows i think that the sun would get
it i know it was tough to wear those
outdoors all day i started getting
worried that i was getting like retinal
damage but then i was like no people do
triathlons and stuff
yeah yeah i couldn't see because mine
were clear so i was just literally like
blind the whole day outside
it's good you guys did that though yeah
let me let me get another shot because i
could feel like
you guys got to be so proud of you guys
are they cool
no they're not that sweet but they're
all right dude can i just sit
oh
so here's the thing he came back
pretending to get a mask
and then he used it as an excuse to
sneak attack you guys
kind of yeah kind of wild yeah i was
bummed because
you can hear in the video i was about to
compliment him on his physique
you know i was like dude i just want to
say yeah i just want to say you got like
like what's your workout
and but they ain't coughed in it but you
know we didn't get to well
you still you're still not sure he
coughed on us on purpose right
yeah i was like kind of like was he it
is a little bit questionable
i mean what well no he turned around he
said what kind of mask do you have
then he coughed and immediately left
yeah the fact that he immediately left
kind of made it seem like it was on
purpose
yeah i i don't know i i tend to be a
little bit naive
but yeah i was at first i was like i was
like oh he just accidentally coughed
but that doesn't make much sense you
know
the thing is a dude like that who's
cruising around without a mass shirtless
call from people that's the dude who
would have the virus
yeah that's the thing too because
they're being reckless all the time yeah
i mean i guess
sometimes it wasn't even getting our ass
kicked i was like one of these people
probably has coveted and they're going
to be wrestling me and breathing all
over me
no but uh you know what you guys got to
do the right thing out there and
like you know like uh you know sometimes
you just gotta march
and and risk your own health for the for
to to make
for the betterment of the world so
that's what you guys are are you guys
worried about covered
oh yeah oh yeah i'm messed up you know
i'm uh we don't really leave the house
well pretty much
we moved our podcasts at home we used to
we usually do it out of a studio
but we uh we do it from home now because
we we just want all of our employees to
be home
except dan he's expendable you guys saw
our producer on screen he's here with us
if he perishes from covid we can accept
that loss but for the most part we want
everyone else to be healthy
no right yeah and that's what i'm
willing to i'm willing to make that
section now we've all been tested we got
tested a lot and we wear masks and stuff
so we're all being said
but um we're really worried about it it
really sucks
well we were in uh what what beach were
we at the other day when we were filming
hunting was it in newport newport is
newport newport
oh nice so those guys like i don't know
what's going on but nobody there
wears masks yeah newport every i think
people in newport are doing so well in
life and they're also like good looking
and healthy that i think they think
they're kind of like
above like bad things happening to them
almost right
right yeah like they're like i crush in
a commercial mortgage lending
i dead lift like 405 and like i i drive
wave runners on the weekend like
nothing's going to kill me and i'm like
but bro i don't know if the virus is
like
cares about those details maybe they're
right though
on the other hand maybe they're right
maybe the virus is like
these guys this guy's crushing it i'm
gonna go and we're skipping newport yeah
all right you put your chill you're
gonna go over that real estate developer
yeah i don't know we were
really shocked by what was going on
there it's kind of like uh
surreal literally no one was wearing a
mask and everyone was just going on with
their life like nothing is going on
oh like and most of all like we were
you know we rented a boat for a video we
were making
and you think that you know in the
service industry people would be
would be more prone to wear a mask
because they're precautious
yeah because they they want to cater to
their customers and not
not make anyone uncomfortable but that
wasn't the case in huntington beach the
coronavirus is
doesn't exist but i did i did bring
masks with me and um at least the people
with us did wear it yeah
they made everything they were nice they
didn't curse us back like in your video
no they were not they were not yeah we
were paying yeah is the difference
yeah we were paying them yeah
you know um you guys have done a lot of
really valuable activism with kovid
with paul walker but the one thing that
i really want to give you guys props on
is your small dong activism
which is obviously uh something that
affects many men including myself
and oh what up dude yeah welcome to the
squad yeah welcome to the fretboard
thank you very glad to have you here
dude
thank you and so i just i feel like it
was really
it really touched me frankly um to see
you guys going out on a limb and doing
this so let me pull this up for
reference we could discuss
uh fighting small donkey together my
boys chad kroger and jt
parr also known as the party bros are
with us
they join me now what's up buddies oh
what's up jesse what up dude dude stoked
here in miami that's one of our favorite
cities
yeah this place is dope you all would
love it down here all right
big super bowl tomorrow night let's just
start off
how do you guys party at a super bowl
party
oh dude good question uh well we have a
huge rager for sure
uh gotta get some brews we usually have
wood ranch cater it maybe get some
burgers and some steaks which is cool
but jesse there's actually
uh an announcement that jt and i we want
to make to the world
oh okay we we have small dongs
yes there's an epidemic of dudes out
there who feel bad about their wieners
and dudes you don't have to like on my
hair i have a small dong
and it's dang guys you can't stand live
shows and
talk about your dongs you can't do it
we're sorry you can't do it we just want
people to know that it's all good dude
yeah you don't have to feel shame and
we're celebrating it dude
we told our dad superman
super bowl predictions chiefs dude i've
never seen anyone make it look as easy
yeah for sure but i do love the diners
because california
um but we will have a rager and if
you're cruising uh you have a small dog
and i really want to see andy win a
super bowl i'll see you later
all right yeah they cut it a [ __ ]
i have a feeling he was not happy about
that and you know i gotta say like
we're talking about important activism
it's it's it's just funny for him to be
like
oh guys we can't talk about your small
dongs on live tv but it's like you know
did uh did martin luther king listen
when they said hey you can't
you know march on washington yeah
yeah they try to tell you what are the
spaces that are okay to talk about
things that are
important and i think sometimes the
importance of what we're talking about
supersedes the importance of the space
so what were you what were you guys
meant to talk about when they invited
you on because clearly it wasn't that
uh yeah they wanted us to talk about our
super bowl predictions
how we were celebrating uh i believe
that's it but i mean we just
you know we're we're fired up and uh on
this new initiative and we're like we
just gotta
you know we're live we gotta tell the
world we have small dongs
and we had a we had a listener who has
like a really small penis
and he was going through a really tough
time and no matter what we told him in
emails or how he corresponded with them
nothing would make him feel better about
his small dick and
we were like well let's let's let's show
them that it is okay to have a small
deal you know
and yeah it was all for you gary oh
shout out to gary little dick that's
also my dad's name which incidentally i
guess i probably get a small dick from
him too
i wonder if that's him you think it's my
dad
yeah our our dads were less than
stoked on the announcement because you
know we're not doubting that i'm in the
process yeah yeah we had a steak dinner
with them and we were like dads look
we're going to tell the world we have
small dicks and you might be implicated
in this
implication yeah yeah what's the
implication
that they have small dicks no i'm saying
the implication is funny oh the
implication's hilarious
do you go did you guys get any kind of
follow-up from that interview was he
upset with you guys i mean obviously he
cut you off early
yeah he he was he was not that fired up
on it
uh yeah they're like we can't really
have you back on after that but
you know you went out with them the best
of it yeah
yeah and i think the message is too
strong you know it's like
i think i think we're just you know
giving
dudes out there the strength to say like
what up world i have a little hog and
i think that's more important yeah some
people said we were banned but we just
were told we couldn't come back on
yeah what's the difference
good question yeah they're kind of the
same thing huh
i think so unless you have some insight
about the difference
you know why by the way is it really
that
uh controversial of a thing to talk
about television i mean you
got you guys say hey we got small dongs
i mean it's not like you're
you didn't even use vulgar language you
guys were totally vulgar i mean dong
what are we talking about here i mean
this is outrageous yeah and jesse said
dong too he's like you guys can't come
on and talk about your dongs
yo what's up yeah uh maybe he should do
his show
what's up maybe he should lose his shell
for using that language
oh dude you know what i think it was
with the surprise factor
because like we test like we were like
all right we have small dongs and then
you can see people aren't used to
hearing people talk about their small
dongs and and i think it kind of through
him it gets everyone who's in the
production room
all the producers jesse it all gets them
thinking about their dongs
and people don't want to be thinking
about their dongs when they're under the
gun like that
so what do you guys what do you guys
characterize as small dongs like is
there a certain threshold
like with menza there's like a certain
iq to join the club
is there is there a length of the penis
that qualifies for small dong
it's a good question i mean i mean the
average length is like
what like five and three-fourths erect
um that's a solid piece yeah that's a
that's a huge
it's a huge dink um but yeah
i don't know i don't you know i think i
think i think honestly it's like if you
feel like you have a small dong
then you know you don't you know all
dongs are hot dogs are chill but you
know
i think it's more about how you feel
about it we don't want to exclude anyone
who feels like they have a small dom
and then you know some people are small
when they're not uh tumescent and some
people are
small when they are and and there's and
then everyone has different ways of
measuring it like do you go this is
really crude i'm sorry but you go like
underneath or to the side
and so um there's a lot of variance i
don't know if there's a standard for for
what is big or small
but i i think it's more about the
feeling and i think we've all felt like
it's small before penis size is kind of
like in the
in the in the heart and soul yeah right
more than the physical body yeah yeah
it's like yeah go ahead i'm sorry just
cut you off chad go ahead please oh no
no worries uh yeah it's like i think
i've you know when i heard the first
heard the term bellend which is a
british term you know it's like
there's like you know sorry to be crude
but there's the you know
the shaft and the bell and i was like
well i just have a bell you know there's
no end it's just the bell and there's
all right that's right and i kind of
knew
you know
you talked about erect you just have a
tip
or like uh i think flask
i think i think there's a little bit
more length there's a little bit more
shaft during the erection phase
yeah yeah that'd be a hell of a thing if
it was just a big mushroom tip
yeah but yeah ones get a little
concerned when we talk too much about
our penises too
like they're like don't tell the world
you have small dongs
like you know like they get worried
about it like
you know like whoever we're dating or
like you know
girlfriends or so the implication even
applies to
the partner yeah what does it mean about
them
that they would be with a guy with a
small opinion what does it say about you
i think it speaks super highly yeah i'm
fired up
yeah you're an ally like uh
because then there's almost like there's
different categories of smallness right
like
there's an actual medical condition of
micro penis which i'm sure you guys are
aware of
which is really and and i don't mean to
to
really don't say this to make fun of
those with this condition but
like an erect penis is like the size of
a jelly bean
so i don't know if you guys what a cool
dude that sounds like yeah
you could be president of whatever
committee we're in for sure
the smaller your penis the more prestige
you have in the community
i think that's what we're hoping for
yeah i mean
back in antiquity days there were small
dogs were all the rage
you know statue of david i mean he's got
he's got a tiny piece
fires me up he probably he was probably
a grower though
and for for us it's about it's about how
you own it you know what i mean
like if you can if you can be in front
of a bunch of dudes
and just pull out your jelly bean dick
and have complete confidence about it
we'll admire you for for not being
afraid
of what you know people would perceive
as a shortcoming for you owning it like
that
that's that's what we're really
encouraging yeah stand up and be like i
got a little dick
but on top of that i got all these other
qualities and i won't be defined
by what you think is a shortcoming yeah
yeah literally
shortcoming yeah
do you guys yeah do you guys have any
tips with those with the
with the small members like how like in
terms of
pleasing a woman or do you find that
size doesn't really even matter in terms
of pleasure i think i think just
bring passion into it yeah bring all you
have
own who you are you know uh to make
my peace with it i like how much
streaking a ton
you know legally i guess it's legal uh
do your pubes cover your entire penis or
like do you trim the pubes to make it
look bigger
i was sponsored by manscaped yeah you
are for real
yeah yeah so so that's why i
tell you that my peeps are short dude
yeah yeah because when you got a small
and you got a small one you really got
to trim the pubes down
to give it like the biggest chance to
flourish
yeah like astro turf yeah
for sure yeah i would tell those dudes
to just be a lot of fun
i think just be a lot of fun and then
yeah that's what matters the most to
people is if they're having a good time
yeah yeah they have this the sex with
like the
penis part that's like i don't know
that's that's
that's a small part of the whole picture
yeah people focus on that completely but
the other stuff matters just as much if
not more yeah
i think that's great i really do
well you guys are inspiring uh yeah i
mean there's so much you guys take
on there's so much you guys stand for i
mean
do you have new videos in the makings
or um anything yeah
social justice there's some other causes
that were
yeah what i mean yeah we're kind of like
in the in the middle
in the in between stages right now um
we're thinking about you know handing
out mass
in different parts of the country um
and then that would be interesting yeah
and then we were thinking about
something with the skate parks
um like they shut down the skate parks
or they put sand into the skate park so
we wanted to oh that's not well hold on
they did that to prevent covid right so
i kind of
wonder where's your heart on that one
yeah well we we're
it's complicated yeah we're on the side
of safety for sure
um but i think we just want we just want
the city
we know skaters are hurt right now and
they feel kind of like personally
attacked even if that's just an
emotional response it's how they
genuinely feel
and we just want the city to show
skaters that
that their hearts are with them as well
you know we want to just get everyone on
the same page
and then chad actually had a genius idea
like 2020 bad [ __ ] just keeps happening
and i think we're
all getting kind of used to just the
unexpected and we want to be prepared
for it so
chad had this fire idea for a phone pit
yeah so uh during during the
the quarantine i've been studying uh
astrophysics a lot and i was like you
know
an asteroid could hit any day and
you know with like the pandemic we're
like did you say
uh so we're like an asteroid could hit
any day and we need to be prepared for
it and like it's like how do
how do dirt bikers brace their falls
when they're trying out new tricks
foam pit so i'm like if we just built a
huge foam pit
um i think that could help with the
asteroid debacle
so you so it's almost like you could
play in it and then once the asteroid
comes and it's like everybody
got a foam pit we gotta absorb this
asteroid yeah i need to think about the
playing in it part two i guess we could
you know
yeah you could you could huck some
corworks threes in there and then when
the asteroids come and just bail
now let me ask you this question um you
know the asteroid
we don't necessarily know where on the
earth it will hit so how do you guys
maneuver
the the foam pit to intercept that
asteroid's impact
so good question
um you just can tell it just tell it
yeah what if it's in the middle of the
ocean
uh well no one's using cruise ships
right now so we could put on a cruise
ship
oh good call dude oh that is a really
good call actually
yeah yeah just got on a carnival
cruise liner carnival cruise saves the
world
yeah yeah they could use the boost did
you guys hear there was like a
a cruise ship that that finally went
back out to sea
and they immediately had a corona virus
outbreak
i did see that really yeah yeah it's
awesome
yeah i mean who would go on a cruise
right now that seems like a suicide
mission
yeah our eagerness seems to be getting
us into trouble with some of this stuff
yes yeah yeah and my mom was actually on
the cruise ship the one of the princess
ones
like in like february really um
oh yeah like the so she was on so
there's that one that got
stuck out are you vaping off the screen
or what i'm sorry to interrupt you chad
but
yeah i'm so sorry i get the feeling that
the jk is doing something off screen i'm
curious about
it keeps dipping up i was too
embarrassed to do it on screen i can't
do it
what are you doing you're hitting a
jewel or what yeah i got a jewel just
show me
okay
[Laughter]
uh yeah so they're the the two princess
cruises so
there's the one so she was on the one
before there's there's one that got
stuck outside of san francisco for like
a week yeah and a bunch of people i got
kobe but she's on the cruise before that
on the same ship so she was on it a week
before
and i guess three or four passengers had
corona
but they didn't tell anyone on the ship
so they found out man
they found out like uh weeks after um
so yeah i'm i'm i'm grateful that she
was
she she got out yeah safely but it was
scary i remember she was like
yeah because before i was like she's
like i was like telling i was like i
don't think you should go on this cruise
because like corona like
some ships are getting stuck out at sea
for like 10 days like that sounds
horrific and she's like well they won't
they won't refund the ticket
so it's like a whole
yeah that was an especially crazy time
because nobody even understood what it
was or
like how deadly it was or what it meant
to have it so
being one of those early uh infections
was especially kind of terrifying and
strange
oh yeah yeah early on it was terrifying
and you're just hearing so many stories
about different things happening to
people from like all age groups and it
was
it was i'm grateful now it seems like
there seems to be a little bit more
understanding as to how it works and
what the probabilities are but it's
still a lot of uncertainty
yeah a lot for sure which is surprising
to me i was like i thought i guess i was
naive about science i was like i thought
science would have it all figured out at
this point like five months in
but it seems like uh i don't know it's
just a
it's a more tricky process than i would
have anticipated yeah yeah
i think the fact that it seems to be
mutating a lot so there's different sort
of like
uh do you call it strains out there or
types so it's um like it yeah which is
that that's scary too though like if
there's a vaccine
i don't even know the science but like
that it's changing too
so people need to be prepared on all
angles i guess
and how it hates different people so
differently it's also really yeah
really wild yeah yeah some people get
like the regular d
some people get like regular coffin and
some people get like the double espresso
shot and you're like
but they seem like healthy you're like
yeah yeah how it's different yeah
well i'm glad you guys are out there
doing activism because it is i mean it's
it's a really important issue and i'm
glad to see you guys are kind of even
moving forward to bigger issues i mean
if we think kovit's bad just wait
until the asteroid comes right so yeah
yeah
glad to hear you guys are working on
that i know you guys have a hulu show in
the works what is going on
congratulations on that i mean
that's great fantastic thank you uh
yeah i don't know we can't dive into the
creative too much but
it's uh but it's an animated show what's
up
animated show um set in ancient greece
uh two two bros greek gods for dads
yeah dads are like oh you guys are like
demigods orwell
yeah yeah that's epic yeah it's epic
literally
and so we're uh it's been fun too
because we've just gotten
i've always loved greek mythology and
we've got to dive back into that world
and like
the gods are like kind of dumb and and
have a lot of like
flaws but they're you know all powerful
too which kind of reminds us of the dads
we grew up with
right and uh not specifically our own
but like just you know like yeah yeah
and then um and yeah we and we loved
like the oc and stuff and it feels like
a kind of world that could get mapped
over
in ancient greece too wow i can't wait
to see that what
do we have some kind of release date uh
uh in mind is this something you guys
are currently working on
yeah it's still super early we gotta get
to our money but
we're optimistic yeah so you guys still
have time to both work
on this show and continue to make your
videos
for sure yeah at the moment at the
moment yeah
i think i think yeah we always kind of
have like multiple projects going and
once so
uh we're pretty good at multitasking i
guess but yeah i think
chad works really really hard i always
have to say this but he like is like a
the hardest working guy i've ever met so
i i have full confidence you can
get it all done yeah i i do love working
for some reason yeah you say he'd get
him all the time you make it sound like
you're not helping at all jt
no i hope i help a lot i do a lot yeah
but but
if if i had my druthers we'd just kick
it yeah yeah yeah
i know that i'm that type too ela kind
of motivates me
um how do you you guys are mostly on
instagram
the views on youtube are criminally low
in my opinion
i hope that everyone goes and subscribes
and watches there but how do you guys
make a
where do you guys get your income mostly
um from our podcasts we like all the
podcasts you guys have a really popular
podcast right
yeah yeah five appearances different
different
like deals that we've made um yeah we
worked various jobs on our way up to and
then i mean i was i was spoiled too my
parents would still hook me up with cash
and stuff so
that made it a lot easier i got more a
lot more swings at the plate than most
people get
um but but now we're actually doing well
with the stuff we've been working on so
we have a couple different revenue
channels that's awesome
yeah i'm happy to hear that i wish you
guys all the continued success
i can't wait for that show that sounds
great
the activism great i'm a huge fan of
youtube not just
bros but like the good bros the theo
you guys are the alpha of the beta
you're not the betas you're the omega
bros
i would like to dub you guys all here
today i mean yeah well thank you
that's nice dude well i'm a huge fan of
you guys so this has been such an honor
to come on yes you're
really fun uh so yeah we loved your
performance or
your appearance on the howard stern show
which was yeah that's really epic i like
how howard's such a fan of you guys
because like he's not really
it's totally out of his lane in terms of
stuff he usually talks about but yeah
somehow he just has
discovered you guys and has this
affinity i find that true of a lot of
other people though like ellen
you know i mean it's kind of bizarre how
you guys
boo i feel like and i don't mean this in
a bad way you guys really resonate with
boomers
yeah we we seem to have a a wide range
like
yeah we'll do like there's a wide range
yeah they'll be like like
if we're in new york like finance bros
will be like fired up you know it is
and there's like moms love us you know
it's it's pretty uh
it's pretty cool that this sort of uh
it's not just like 18 to 25 year olds
it's it's sort of like
like when we first hit we did like a uh
a a speech at like a a lunch at disney
for like disney lawyers for like disney
can i say that jt yeah absolutely yeah
yeah for like disney lawyers they're
like we love your stuff it
like helped us get through a deal like
that's awesome
yeah we're waiting for like a dictator
to like our stuff and then we can go
over there well china is pretty close
yeah yeah that's yeah yeah north korea
yeah they're hot
in north korea
[Laughter]
and also also you guys have a a podcast
that that's doing
fantastic uh going deep with chad
and jt available everywhere oh you guys
have a patreon excellent
i gotta hop on over there yeah we've
been a little
uh not great about the patreon patreon
go support them directly yes
god damn it right yeah yeah
not so angry maybe
well guys i wish you all the continued
success in the world
and i'll be following closely watching
your every
move dude thank you yeah thank you yeah
it's so fun to be on i'm such a fan
so thank you it's uh it's been great to
talk to you guys i appreciate you saying
that really nice to meet you guys we
love your content yeah
all right guys well take care likewise
and uh we love you so yeah so be safe
and god bless
and keep those small dicks keep those
small dicks you know
do you guys ever do exercises to prolong
your dick i know there are things you
could do
dude i wasted years of my life trying to
find ways to make it bigger
and i just at some point had to accept
it is what it is because there's so many
remedies out there but i get the feeling
none of them work right
yeah i don't think any of them dig pumps
uh i know i think that's
the football player used to hang
dumbbells from it
does that work because i feel like
that'll probably just make you impotent
yeah i think it's good for mental
toughness but i don't think it has any
other benefits
right sure i feel like that's focusing
on the wrong
um taking the wrong approach about it
acceptance
yeah yes acceptance and um well
sometimes before you get to acceptance
eli you gotta tug on your dick for
eight hours a day
[Laughter]
all right guys appreciate y'all take
care
lots of luck everything else
thanks guys all right thank you thank
you meet you guys
so great to meet you bye
you